le studio de divertissement multimédia
de montréal moman factory qui est
derrière les parcours nocturne lui mina
poursuit son expansion en france de
nouvelles annonces aujourd'hui on n'a
pas tout de suite avec éric fournier qui
est associé producteur exécutif de
moment factory on le rejoint à paris
eric fourni bonsoir
bonsoir j'ai l'âme vous êtes où
exactement à paris là
mais on est devant carmen dans le
quartier de pigalle oui et là vous avez
annoncé donc des partenariats
aujourd'hui donc partenariat avec
cultive halles qui est un opérateur
touristique culturelle puis des
collaborations également avec le musée
de l'armée les invalides
oui effectivement on a annoncé
aujourd'hui que on allait faire un
spectacle permanent au dôme de reva
liste des cent vallées donc un spectacle
qui va être ouvert au public à partir de
l'automne prochain pour visant alors
c'est un projet qui y perd stratégique
pour le développement international
ça veut dire quoi exactement pour moi
même facture que cette expansion en
france
mais c'est la suite logique d'une série
de d'événements de projets qu'on a fait
ici où finalement avec le temps on ne
bâtit un réseau on a bâti une réputation
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on peut faire
des projets de plus en plus important et
qui nous permettent aussi de bâtir un
bureau un studio important pour mon
vanczak terry ici à paris vous êtes déjà
en france le dif est déjà depuis
plusieurs années des projets des
expériences lumineuse comme vous faites
là ici
oui on a déjà deux lui la
[Musique]
france est ensuite plusieurs autres
projets dont un projet avec partouche à
aix-en-provence donc notre des projets
en france ont lancé depuis plusieurs
années est-ce qu est-ce que j'ai raison
de penser que l'essentiel de vos projets
maintenant puisque vous prenez de
l'expérience puis vous exportez votre
produit se fait à l'étranger 2
non je pense que c'est plus une façon de
travailler en collaboration locales et
montréal dans un monde post pandémique
ou les voyages doivent être mieux géré
je pensais pourtant d'avoir aussi des
talents des artisans locaux qui
travaillent avec nous aux équipes de
montréal alors si plus dans une logique
de collaborations travail des équipes
virtuelles hybride et donc quand vous
signer des contrats comme vous venez
faire en france c'est quoi les
répercussions pour le siège social pour
les activités au québec
mais le projet aura les invalides et la
suite de aura à la basilique dans le
fond c'est le premier projet qui a donné
naissance ce ces deux spectacles ces
femmes un projet qu'on ne fait que en
2007 à la basilique notre-dame qui dans
le fond nous donner cette cet axe de
développement alors ce que ça veut dire
pour des équipes de montréal c'est de
travailler sur des projets de plus en
plus important de plus en plus
spectaculaire donc ça donne des vitrines
pour mon manufacturier un peu partout
sur la planète
quand les projets sur lesquels vous
travaillez présentement en france seront
ils prêts
le projet d un gars qui est le projet
dont on vient de parler on prévoit
l'ouverture donc le début de la
diffusion à partir de l'automne prochain
de 20 22 donc on a un an pour livrer le
projet on a aussi annoncé aussi
aujourd'hui soissons qui est un projet
dans la première capitale de la france
qui a une heure de paris où on va faire
des installations multimédias dans toute
la ville alors ça c'est un projet de
trois ans et on continue avec le
développement de nos lumena 2020 a quand
même été une année difficile pour tout
le monde mais pour vous notamment il ya
eu des mises à pied il ya eu des baisses
de salaires notamment pour les
gestionnaires de moment factory est ce
que tout ça maintenant c'est du passé
vous êtes revenu à votre ère d'allée
d'avant pandémie
oui absolument je pense que c'est un peu
comme si le monde avait ralenti et l'eau
de pluie depuis le printemps tout
s'accélère des projets qui étaient sur
la glace son matériel des nouveaux
projets arts inc et là on est à la
recherche d'une centaine de personnes
pour nous aider à répondre à cette
renouveau postpandémique vous avez
réembaucher tout le monde
ben oui on a on en iran du haut niveau
qui est presque prêt pandémique et l'on
cherche comme si tout à l'heure une
centaine de talent de créatif on n'est
combler les besoins nous aider
vous avez combien d'employés chez momint
ses 350 350 félicitations bonne soirée à
paris merci beaucoup eric fourni
merci beaucoup pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit